he is Michael Phelps here on the Rich
Eisen show what's up Michael it's been
too long since we've talked I know I
know it has been better for talking to
you I want to get I want to get right
into it obviously we I want to talk
about the fact that it's the fifth
annual imagine a day without water but I
want to get right into what you think
about your Ravens at five and two what
do you think well obviously I love it I
mean you got we have we have excitement
we and we get to get I mean we have a
chance every single week I think that's
something I've looked towards through
for a while and and you know seeing true
emotion on on Lamar's face every single
game and she didn't pissed off when he
doesn't make a good throw you know like
that's something I love seeing as an
athlete and and you know kind of
watching him really be able to fit into
the NFL and and you know really do what
he does best it's it's it's incredible
to watch him we got
I mean having Marcus Peters there's a
great ad now hopefully we can get that
secondary healthy engrams and sane and
yeah I mean we're looking good I'm I'm
excited the rest of our division isn't
that good first time in a while we
haven't had to basically go toe to toe
with Pittsburgh yeah I mean I could talk
to you forever about this I know I know
that's what I wanted to start with this
and it's interesting you know we started
the show talking about what's the most
dangerous athlete out there because you
know this kid Juan Soto is the well he's
the proverbial like young athlete who
doesn't know how difficult it is right
right and how that's dangerous another
dangerous athlete is someone who's been
told he can't and I think Lamar Jackson
falls into that category would you agree
with that I mean 100% and honestly I
think you you really got a chance to see
what kind of work he was doing in the
offices you know I mean when you saw in
the last couple games last year where
you know some things kind of fell off
you know he's more comfortable in the
pocket making a throw his throws are
accurate the guys got wheels you know so
it's like plus you have all the weapons
that he does
you know it's it's fun watching him kind
of come into his own you know have you
met him Michael Phelps have you met I'm
not no I haven't been able to travel
back for too many games but I I'm hoping
to actually get out to the Rams game at
the end of next month
Rams Ravens and the next and end of next
month in LA yeah there's also one that's
coming up against the Patriots in a
couple weeks now now the gay I think
just just because of the history that
we've had and especially at New England
man
anything is possible I think we can beat
him but I honestly their defensive
sneaky good this year and obviously
Brady's Brady and he's the greatest of
all time so he's dangerous we've had
we've had I think one game over the last
five years where we were up 14 points
two different times and lost right so
anything's possible at that Stadium and
and definitely gonna be a challenging
week hopefully have a goodbye and
hopefully the defense can get to Brady
that's something that that that that
offensive line does so well and and his
his jersey stays pretty cleans it it
sure does
they might shake things that Michael
Phelps here in the Rich Eisen show
another athlete type that we mentioned
at the top of our show that's
particularly dangerous is the individual
who's one at all has it all and still
stays at it because it's not enough
because of that Bob that fire that burns
inside it's so rare Brady has it and it
seems like you have that as well or did
have that my question to you is do you
and Brady have have you ever had a
conversation with Brady about that very
subject Michael I don't think we've ever
dove into anything like that we've been
around each other a few times obviously
the Under Armour connection but no I
mean I think I think the greats in like
the best of the best there are so many
similarities I think that we all have
and and the
similarities that we have are things
that are unteachable you know kind of
that that next gear that different level
you know it's always fun being around
athletes who who are greats whether it's
Peyton or Brady or you know and anybody
like that because it's always for me
it's always interesting to see how they
work always fun to see what they're you
know super gung-ho about or how they're
taking care of their body or you know
what little things they're doing every
day to make everything count you know so
I think that's that's just something for
me that I love being around great
athletes because we're similar but we're
also very different and it's tough for
folks to kind of conceive Michael that
what goes into the desire to keep going
isn't just about pride or
professionalism it's about family it's
about kids maybe being old enough to see
mom or dad still do it and I'm wondering
you know maybe that's part of the reason
with Brady his kids are getting older
and being able to enjoy the moment just
showed a photograph of Brady holding his
beautiful daughter up on the podium last
year did that have anything to do with
you getting back in the pool last time
no I I don't think it had anything with
me anything to do with me getting back
into the pool I think it was icing on
top of the cake you know being able to
so my last Olympics with our firstborn
you know was incredible and I never
thought I would have that moment but you
know I guess I do kind of feel bad for
the other two in a way that's you tube
Michael there's you tube for that don't
worry but it's always funny listening to
that hearing that question today I think
Chris and I think CP said to me he was
like this trust me is like your kids are
gonna be like daddy how come you're not
out there they're like what are you
doing how come you know how come you
can't get out there and compete at that
level it's it's it's going to be a wild
I guess thing to realize this if we all
do go to Tokyo next year and they're
like dad what's going on
but now I I think it was really awesome
and also if you look at Tiger - Tiger
had that you know this this year being
able to come back and win the Masters
and and you know have his kids there too
to be able to witness him still do that
it's something that's so cool and and
you know it's got to feel pretty
incredible for for the dads to be able
to prove that to their kids you know to
show them what hard work and dedication
is and to show them what what happens
when you do you know put a bunch of time
into something that you're passionate
about Michael Phelps 23 time Olympic
gold medalist here on the Rich Eisen
show what are your plans for Japan Tokyo
in 2020 what do you plan on doing to
that Stan so being happy working at some
point and some capacity over there I'll
have a handful of people are competing
in my suit I said something that's going
to be pretty cool to watch and and you
know that you know for me as a kid
growing up you know looking at Jordan
and what he did with the Jordan Brand
was something that I wanted to do in the
sport of swimming being able to have my
own some line and now being able to kind
of hand select the dream team so you
will and you know kind of help them be
able to accomplish whatever goals and
dreams they have so it's kind of fun to
be able to really just see these young
up and comers but also seeing it all
come together you know it's it's going
to be pretty pretty sweet and pretty I
mean I guess it's hard to put into words
because it's something that I have
jumped about for so long and and I'm
just looking forward to that moment
where I get to see these guys with all
the Hardys these men and women who have
put all this hard work and time into
something that's so important to them
and so challenging just to be able to be
there at that world stage would be very
very exciting how did a kid from
Baltimore get to Ann Arbor Michael I've
always wanted to ask you that question
obviously you're smart but that goes
without saying being going to Michigan
but how did you wind up with that
connection well when your coach says if
I take a coaching job will you come with
me
I say yes okay that's one one way to do
it but I always wanted to go to Michigan
Michigan was always something that you
know they date I guess they always had a
great swimming program
and I knew the head coach there very
well so for me it was just a so I guess
it really was a dream actually to be
able to do that you know looking back at
some of the photos from my first
Olympics I was actually in a Michigan
hat back then so it was kind of weird
how everything worked out but being able
to spend four years there is was
incredible I wish we had a better
football struggles I know how it works
but yeah that that is very challenging
to watch week in and week out I know
Notre Dame man this this is it though
this is gonna be I mean I am yeah I mean
I I think honestly I think I would take
if we could win only one game the
restaurant because I want it to be Ohio
State more than anything that's what I
wanted to do well so it will see that
game is going to be hard as it always is
but hopefully we're not so far out of it
by that time and and hopefully we can
you know pull the team together I'm
pumped to see how they come come back
after that loss and and are able to
battle against a great team like Notre
Dame me too
Michael but I look I don't mean to
correct you certainly on live TV and
radio but it's the Ohio State okay it's
deal because we don't want to confuse
them with an Ohio state right it could
just be like we don't know which oh hi
oh state is it's the Ohio State okay
Michael people from Michigan don't say
that we will actually say the school
name it's no big deal to us you know
like we're not like to school down south
or you know that's cool like you know TT
use us or whatever like we don't we
don't you know or DDS you know I we
don't we could say it you know what I'm
saying I hear you let's get into what
what's really important obviously is our
planet and making sure that we save it
as best we possibly can what is the
fifth annual imagine a day without water
what is this about Michael Phelps well
think about the question
like think about a day without water
that's no brushing your teeth that's no
washing clothes you're not going to have
any coffee there's no water to brush
your teeth so it's like if you think
about everything you do in a day without
water life would be even more difficult
than it is right now so you know I think
it's something that's so simple for all
of us to jump on board to turn the water
off from here when you're brushing teeth
you know somebody literally as simple as
that will save sixty four glasses and
can save up to four gallons and if you
think over the last three years that
we've been doing this it's it we don't
we're working on trying to get the exact
numbers but I know it is over fifty
billion gallons of water that we've been
able to save in three years and yes
that's a ton of water but we need to do
more we need to stay on top of all of
these small things that are going to
make a big difference for the future
because what if there's what if there is
a day where nobody in the world is able
to turn on their faucet and get clean
water because we see this problem
already occurring so you know for me I'm
honestly trying to just help people
understand how important it is to pay
attention to something that is shown
needed for everyday life and if we can
conserve as much as we can by turning
off the faucet and just being conscious
about I think it's something that that's
so important yeah every drop counts dot
Colgate dot-com to learn about more
created by the u.s. water Alliance and
its value of water campaign hey Michael
how often you get in the pool with your
kids do you do it or you're just like
you know dad dad's had enough of that
my kids are boomers in the water almost
every day okay I'm not in the water with
him every day somebody cuz I I get in
every now and then with him he if we're
ever in together when we're when we're
in together he always he always
basically just points and tells me to go
or swim butterfly or some freestyle he
always likes that but but I think one
thing as a dad I'll say
watching him in the pool he's fearless
and and he's extremely comfortable and
confident in the water and that's
something that is very incredible to see
as a dad because it's it's you know as
scary as the pool is it's an absolute
amazing place and and you know it brings
a gigantic smile every time he's in
there just going crazy and splashing
around well Michael it's great seeing
you being a dad you know obviously
America's watched you grow up sir and
you know being a father of three now
correct yeah and and just seeing
everything that you are and what you
want to do from here on out I'm all in
just let me know however I can help and
be part of it
awesome I love it rich thank y'all so
much for having me and I look forward to
seeing soon yeah you bet maybe I'll be
at that Monday night game - hopefully
we'll connect we'll see you soon look
forward right back at you Michael Phelps
23 time Olympic gold medalist here on
imagine a day without water v am an
annual version of that at Michael Phelps
on Twitter at em underscore Phelps
double zero for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app